and this man won the honorary accolade
at the German football ambassador awards
at 18 thomas hitzlsperger went to
England to join Aston Villa after ninety
nine appearances he signed to Stuttgart
where he won the Bundesliga in 2007 the
Munich native also earned 52 caps for
Germany his fierce left foot earned him
the nickname hits the hammer at Villa
but he's had an impact off the pitch to
making commitments to a range of good
causes especially against discrimination
and racism you moved abroad when you
were 18 to Aston Villa her first
professional club would you have dreamed
back then that you would one day become
a German football ambassador never I had
totally different things on my mind when
I moved to Birmingham to become a
professional player I didn't see the big
pink shell discourse a gun sick is he in
yes sitting here a few years later after
getting the award was a huge development
in articular what was the most important
thing you learned there I set myself the
goal of becoming a professional
footballer and after a bumpy start I
succeeded then I suddenly noticed how
much more than was to being a player you
are now a role model you talk to kids
and they listen to and watch closely
what you're saying and doing what these
are calling no answer name and taking on
that role is a special job and one that
I'm still aware I today one done this is
omnes II as a Zonda Dolph gave it on
Justin push me off i did oculist gaps
was there a special moment when you
realized you were more than just a
footballer it's kappa estimate imam
there were times when I was confronted
with prejudice Oh players who come up to
me and say things that surprised me but
the image of Germans back then was
something I did want to challenge
because it wasn't all positive positive
possessed well it's because language is
so important I wanted to learn it
quickly you might think English isn't
that hard for us to learn
when marketing but the different accents
can make it difficult the elected demise
I'm took about a year for me to be able
to master the Birmingham dialect 15
content husband what kinds of prejudices
were you confronted with else confronted
would at a sensible knowledge silly
stuff like the music you listen to I was
into American music like hip-hop but and
that surprised the other players they
assume Germans would only listen to
German music ain't fought were tired it
took me back at first but really these
are minor things that you deal with soon
enough some things like punctuality
that's a cliche but one that applied in
my case it was something the English
appreciated and I didn't want to
disappoint them I always made an effort
but if you don't manage it one time
people are really surprised and then
they wind you up it sorta yeah my you
once said kids had asked how you can
shoot so hard and you said it takes ten
years practice hitting the ball against
a wall too much ma'am I couldn't play
with my brothers and sisters I grew up
on a farm whether we're concrete walls I
could shoot against I noticed how my
technique and power improved I just
enjoyed doing it then I told that story
when people ask me later hospet it there
must be other people who've done it to
weather for ten years or two weeks I
remembered how I used to listen
carefully to players when I was a
youngster telling us how to succeed as a
professional folks it's it isn't a
perfect life and it's the same today
kids watch exactly what their heroes do
what they wear how they play and what
they say clear and is there a point
where you notice you're a role model
with responsibility good on this is yes
eventually people would say you're
famous could you help us with our cause
hunters two phones kazakh it was torn
well it made me think what exactly do I
want to do outside of football how much
time do
have to spend on training and how much
do I have for other things little by
little I noticed that I wanted to use my
popularity to support issues that
interested me such as fighting
xenophobia racism and anti-semitism
because I was a foreigner myself buddy
Sceptile in love are so the motivation
was personal good no this is exactly but
you also have to watch out with football
if you are form then it's turned back on
if you have other commitments people
then say he's busy with too many other
things to them under adding it finding a
balance isn't easy because football is
always number one you no mind to submit
a full spelled out that Chopin you have
a responsibility to the fans and the
club I lists a tool you've recently
become interested in journalism why
wasn't I wanted to stay in football once
my playing days were over I didn't want
to go into coaching right away or any
other job at a cloud water park I wanted
to see the other side Isaiah 42
underside is a vowel mrs. Magoo why is
it so difficult sometimes for
journalists to get access to players an
interview that I fancied experiencing
their side and testing out whether i
could write and seeing what other
stories people were interested in what
would you want to see if you were my
editor-in-chief this cat except the main
job is the matches of course people who
take an interest the team line-ups and
tactics alpha tactic the sporting aspect
yes but there are a lot of other
political issues connected to football
nitish attended FIFA is obviously very
topical and needs to be addressed well
not dog about masturbation I find
investigative journalism fascinating
people who go where it hurts as it were
we taught these people do a really
valuable job they go deeper yes exactly
most people want to be entertained and
that's something you have to provide but
as we are seeing there are a lot of
problems and there are always good
journal
who follow up on a story and do great
work she has a good just like those
people who give others what they want to
see entertainment something to talk
about and something that's easy to
consume like to consume Eunice